how many submissions is Holi short
received each of the past five years
yeah so in the five years ago we were at
around 2000 or so submissions for that
year this past year we received 5,000
submissions so we've in between that
we've gone from 2,000 to 5,000 for the
last five years increased around 500 or
so each of those years so 2,000 2,500
3,000 3,500
so on so forth to now or last year we're
at five thousand submissions for
fourteenth year this is our 15th year
coming up and we're expecting
potentially six thousand submissions
that's a big increase and we might jump
up a thousand this year based on
averages of course hourly we're deadline
is coming up next Friday so you know
we're estimating what it could be so
yeah it's seen a big jump these last
five years definitely very cool of those
multi thousand plus films that you've
received since the inception of Holi
shorts how many would you say you've
personally watched a lot I say it used
to be hundred percent now it's not as
possible
with the amount of films and a lot
family and new duties and things on top
of that it's probably a good idea at
least 80% of all the films Wow
I've not even more I mean there's just
the last few years we've grown a review
team where I'm overseeing the process
more now and watching certain scores and
rewatching some films and watching my
own but I'm not just hands down watching
everything like it was before say five
years ago where I was literally just
hunkered down watch every single film mm
films is much easier than watching five
to six thousand naturally just time
permitting right so I'd say that's
probably a healthy and safe number
because I'm I like to I'd like to see
everything as much as I can possibly do
you know it's just it's a personal sense
of pride and also maybe maybe have to be
trolling I don't know make sure I'm
always yeah so so there's that part of
it and of course at the end films that
I'm of course watching in or their
people are watching and reviewing the
scores I'm gonna program the films that
program the festival so in the end the
films that do get in I'm watching all of
them so of that number you asked if you
look at the number of the films are
accepted or in the festival those that
watch on your set
so naturally so yeah I'm gonna review
scores of other judges and say okay I
want to watch these these these I'm
gonna make sure let's see what they're
talking about here and kind of just
double-check their work and if I like
the films and then I can sort of makes
that sort of passive approval I'll be
the one to program the film so you know
I'm sort of I guess the last go round if
it gets it or not kind of thing I'm
curious about this review team who are
they and how do you screen them to know
that they're really indie film fans well
we do a process of sort of give them a
soft start right like okay hey you know
this is our criteria this is what we
look for we have a very big breakdown
very thorough breakdown of how we judge
how we score what we're looking for what
the process is understanding how many
films come in because you know if you if
you just watch films for for the film
right if you just watching a film you
might like a film you know and you think
it's okay and there's there's elements
you like those elements you don't like
well you're like oh well this this has a
chance or something you might score
maybe a little lenient or something not
understanding that there are six
thousands submissions and is only formed
in spots that actually can get in so the
number is what five five to eight
percent can actually make the festival
it's very competitive so if you're
looking at it from that standpoint and
only watch five to ten films they may
not understand the full scope of how
many films are there does that make
sense
like there's a lot of films to watch so
if they're just looking at their batch
they may not understand the full scope
so we try to break down a very thorough
you know like listed out email of what
we're looking for what the scope of how
many films we receive what kind of films
we have received looking at the lineups
from the years past we share the lineups
hey look at these review our schedules
so you understand what we've shown what
kind of films we show genres styles
different things you know so they
understand when they're looking at the
films like okay what is the full scope
of how the festival programs and what
we've had before what we're looking for
and things like that
so we give them all that and and again
assign only a few films to start if we
love their results and then feel it's on
par with what we're looking for then
we'll keep them on board to review many
more films and you know and oversee the
process if it's just - if usually
tooling in is more of troubling for me
personally honestly we do it is a very
competitive festival and obviously we
don't want someone who's just every film
is obviously a home run and it's amazing
and you watch the
not on par that's not what we're looking
for now all the same time if you're too
harsh it's also you know something it
could be a fantastic film and they're
grading it like a three out of ten and
it's like okay you're you're being you
know unreasonable so there's both sides
you don't want that and if that's the
case then we just sort of you know
sometimes we let them know hey we just
moving on or some people just you know
quite honestly we just you know move on
or no respond like alright you know
we're going in the direction we just
kind of like you know look for other
people and things like that but yeah
that's that's basically the sort of
process if we like what their early work
is with a few films then we can keep
them on for more if the people that you
know in the film industry
is there anyone that's watched as many
short films as you have you went to you
um
I don't know you know I would say
probably no I think now at this time now
like we talked about this years ago I'd
say who knows I don't know I think it's
safe to say you know when you look at
the math of all the films over all this
many years and since we're just shorts
actually shorts only and not the
features I think we've probably watched
as many shorts as anyone in the world I
guess a lot of movies you watch so start
thinking like yeah have I watched more
shorts and anyone I don't know it sounds
weird to say but it's possible I think I
don't know it's a lot of films I mean
you're talking at least I mean it's say
on average 15 years average is twenty
five hundred films let's just say what
is that number that's 2,000 but at
thirty thousand movies or something I
don't know it's a lot of movies so we've
seen a lot of shorts yeah so yeah
you